for nearly 16 years youtube has been a
dominant force on the internet
billions of people log on to watch
videos from their favorite youtubers
some of which live right here in las
vegas eight news now reporter kate
houston spoke with two content creators
who over several years have become some
of the most popular youtubers
in town we have
a huge ambition a huge passion for
filmmaking and
acting for over 10 years hilly and
hannah hindi have parodied popular
movies and tv shows
such as stranger things in lord of the
rings on their channel
the hillywood show it looks huge and
well produced
and it's just us it's just us we're not
sponsored we don't have a network behind
us
and we do it all on our own the process
of producing a video takes months at a
time
with each parity uploaded anywhere from
six months to a year between each other
the channel has grown to nearly two
million subscribers with fans across the
globe
including the people they're parodying
due to high production costs the
hillywood show cannot rely solely on ad
revenue from youtube
so they're financially supported by fan
donations through the service patreon
which is a membership platform where
fans can get exclusive content through
their subscription
we are so thankful for the fan donations
we are so thankful for the fans
supporting us but
sometime in their life i would like them
not to
have to give i want them just to watch
and to enjoy
the hillywood show is one of many
youtube channels based in las vegas
like hillywood andrew foy has been
creating videos on youtube
for years i i'll always get these
comments and it'll be like i've been
watching since 100k i've been watching
since you were 10 years old
now 19 the fingerstyle guitarist has
amassed nearly 3 million subscribers by
putting out covers of popular songs
over the years foy has grown his channel
by adding vlogs q a's and collaborations
with his younger sister
that pushed the channel in a different
direction and it definitely
helped because those videos have done
really well foy says youtube is like a
full-time
job he's been able to use the money
generated from a partnership with
guitartricks.com
and ad revenue to help pay for college
his car
and build a savings moving forward foy
wants to continue to develop his music
here in las vegas my next big thing is
probably
creating original music a lot of people
a lot of people have been asking me for
original music as restrictions are
loosened the hillywood show hopes to get
back on set
and continue their conversations with
studios to take the show
even further even though we do
everything
we are at a point where we're ready for
some for a team kate houston 8 news now
now many of you may be wondering well
how do you create a youtube channel and
how can someone make
money from it well here it is the first
steps are fairly simple
on youtube.com go to create an account
and then just start uploading your
content
once a channel has a certain amount of
subscribers they can apply for the
youtube partner program this allows
channels to make money from ad revenue
from memberships merchandise
now while this allows content creators
to put some money in their pocket don't
forget
google does take a percentage of that
revenue
other channel will use the
subscription-based service
patreon as you mentioned there in kate's
story which allows fans to donate money
and support them
another big way to make money is through
a sponsored brand deal where a youtuber
will partner with a company
and advertise their product for more
details on the requirements for the
youtube partner program and to hear the
full interviews with the hillywood show
and andrew foy you can head to our
website at
8newsnow.com